[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen von Norbert
Lehmann erfahren Sie alles Wichtige aus
der Welt des Sports
und wir schauen wie viel der Bund im
nächsten Jahr ausgeben will
445 Milliarden für Deutschland die
Regierung beschließt Lindners Haushalt
schmerzhafte Sparmaßnahmen inklusive
mit der genschere in die Zukunft der
Landwirtschaft die EU-Kommission will
gehen Pflanzen zulassen mit
Einschränkungen
und ein Herbststurm mitten im Sommer
tiefpoli fegt über die Niederlande und
Norddeutschland es gibt Tote und große
Schäden
der Haushaltsentwurf für 2024 war eine
schwere Geburt heute hat ihn das
Kabinett beschlossen gut 445 Milliarden
Euro Bundesausgaben sind vorgesehen das
sind etwa 30 Milliarden Euro weniger als
in diesem Jahr denn trotz einer Krise
nach der anderen soll die Schuldenbremse
eingehalten und gespart werden wo genau
gekürzt wurde und wofür ist das meiste
Geld gibt das zeigt den jetzt kommen sie
ja
der allergrößte Teil des Haushalts ist
auch im kommenden Jahr wieder für Arbeit
und Soziales vorgesehen knapp 172
Milliarden Euro das sind 5,5 Milliarden
mehr als in diesem Jahr größter Posten
darin die Rentenversicherung mehr Geld
fließt auch in die Verteidigung
51,8 Milliarden Euro ein Plus von 1,7
Milliarden kein wirklicher Zuwachs denn
der Betrag deckt nur sollt und
Lohnerhöhungen
Rüstungsprojekte finanzieren will man
durch ein Sondervermögen und auch für
den Verkehr gibt's mehr gut 3 Milliarden
Schwerpunkt der Schienenausbau
fast alle weiteren Ressorts etwa Bildung
und Forschung bekommen weniger Geld den
größten Einschnitt soll nach dem Ende
von Corona der gesundheitsetat hinnehmen
16,2 Milliarden Euro ein Minus von 8
Milliarden auch das ressort-familie 13
Milliarden muss mit einer knapperen
Kasse auskommen und zwar mit 218
Millionen Euro weniger
und beim Familienministerium zu sparen
ist ja auch im Gespräch für
Besserverdienende das Elterngeld zu
streichen über die Kritik am
Haushaltsentwurf berichtet Patricia
Wiedemeier
selten waren die Verhandlungen über den
Haushalt so schwer wie in diesem Jahr
nach umfangreichen Hilfspaketen bedingt
durch Corona und den ukraine-krieg
sollen nun wieder gespart werden die
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse oberstes
Ziel des Finanzministers
445,7 Milliarden das wäre nach den
vergangenen Krisenjahren eine deutlich
geringere Neuverschuldung die sich auch
sofort setzen soll trotz der nahezu
täglichen Ausgaben Wünsche die an die
Bundesregierung herangetragen werden und
auch das
Einfallsreichtums was zu tun ist im
politischen Umfeld ist das ein klares
Signal dass Deutschland sich bekennt zu
langfristig
tragfähigen Staatsfinanzen
die meisten Ressourcen sparen umstritten
bleiben vor allem die geplante Kürzung
des Elterngeldes für Einkommen ab
150.000 Euro und der Etat für die Kinder
Grundsicherung Kritik von
Sozialverbänden dem DGB und der
Opposition
die armen Kinder sind die größten
Verliererinnen Verlierer weil es gibt
ein Streit über das Elterngeld aber bei
den armen Kindern kommt nichts an wir
brauchen eine gerechtere Gesellschaft
und das heißt dass diejenigen die starke
Schultern haben mehr Last und tragen
müssen hier sagen wir wir brauchen eine
Vermögenssteuer und wir brauchen eine
Erbschaftssteuer die Union kritisiert
das mit diesem Haushalt zu wenig für die
Wirtschaft getan werde wir müssen auch
investieren das heißt wir müssten jetzt
eigentlich auch wirklich Geld in die
Hand nehmen weil Deutschland fällt im
Moment wirtschaftlich dramatisch zurück
wir brauchen ein anschubprogramm für
Investitionen und Wachstum das würde den
Haushalt sanieren viel Diskussionsstoff
also jetzt geht der Entwurf in den
Bundestag denn der hat den
Haushaltsfragen das letzte Wort
nach langem Hin und Her hat das Kabinett
jetzt also den Haushaltsentwurf
beschlossen
ich wage mal die Prognose nein der
Haushaltsentwurf geht ja jetzt in den
Bundestag wird dort ausführlich beraten
und erst im November dann endgültig
verabschiedet und wie könnte es anders
sein in der Ampel natürlich gibt es noch
viele Differenzen viel Zeit also auch
für Diskussionen und Streit
Außenministerin baerbock hat wie man so
heute hörte eine sogenannte
Protokollnotiz abgegeben das heißt sie
hat noch Vorbehalte bei ihrem Etat die
FDP hatte dies auch beim Gebäude
Energiegesetz gemacht die Folgen haben
wir ja erlebt in den letzten Wochen und
die Diskussion um die Kürzungen des
Elterngeldes hat gerade erst begonnen
die FDP hat ja wiederholt erklärt dass
sie das nicht mitmachen will bleibt dann
noch die Kinder Grundsicherung bis Ende
August muss Familienministerin Lisa
Pauls einen Gesetzentwurf vorlegen auch
das birgt noch erhebliches
Streitpotential es sei jetzt Zeit für
die Sommerpause das täte allen gut war
hier heute oft zu hören im Bundestag ich
fürchte daraus wird wohl nichts
Einschätzung von Patricia danke schön
übermorgen soll der Bundestag das
heizungsgesetz beschließen bei vielen
herrscht dazu nach wie vor
Verunsicherung vor allem wegen der hohen
Kosten jetzt wurde bekannt wie der Staat
dabei unterstützen will wer etwa in
einem Einfamilienhaus eine
klimafreundliche Heizung einbauen lässt
soll dafür maximal 21.000 Euro dazu
bekommen können je nach Einkommen aber
weniger mit der Deckelung will der Staat
preiswucher verhindern
und wir bleiben beim Geld es geht um die
PKW-Maut die war ja ein Prestigeprojekt
vor allem der CSU und ist damaligen
Verkehrsministers andreas Scheuer
verwirklicht wurde die Maut nicht sie
ist gescheitert am EU-Recht für die
SteuerzahlerInnen wird es jetzt teuer
das Verkehrsministerium und die
Betreiberfirmen haben sich auf die Höhe
des Schadensersatzes geeinigt
243 Millionen Euro Christiane hübscher
und Klausberg
die Dimension wird deutlich als scheuers
Nachfolger am frühen Abend vor die
Kameras tritt seine sehr hohe
Schadensumme immer noch das ist nahezu
eine viertel Milliarde Euro und das ist
Geld für das die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
in unserem Land hart gearbeitet haben
die Idee wenn deutsche Pkw-Fahrer Maut
im Ausland zahlen sollen ausländische
Fahrer auch hier zur Kasse gebeten
werden gedacht als wahlkampfschlager der
CSU wurde das Projekt zum ruhrkripiere
gescheitert Juni 2019 vor dem
Europäischen Gerichtshof doch noch im
Dezember zuvor hatte der damalige
Verkehrsminister scheuer Verträge mit
zwei Betreiberfirmen abgeschlossen
Vorwürfe im Untersuchungsausschuss im
Bundestag wie es scheuer zurück ich
verstehe den Unmut auch über dieses
Projekt und die Entwicklung dazu fakt
ist aber
dass wir rechtens gehandelt haben mit
dieser Rechtsauffassung aber blieb
scheuer stets weitgehend alleine bis
heute für mich ist unverständlich wie es
dazu kommen konnte dass man in dieser
Frage Verträge unterschrieben hat bevor
die gerichtlichen Entscheidungen
vorgelegen haben aber es ist nicht meine
Aufgabe zurückzublicken meine Aufgabe
ist es nach vorne zu blicken und überall
dort wo ich Schaden begrenzen kann
diesen Schaden zu begrenzen das ist gut
dass ich jetzt die Bundesregierung auf
diesen Vergleich geeinigt hat und damit
findet jetzt eben dieses Maut Desaster
das europarechtlich von vornherein
verfassungswidrig war gegen alle
Warnungen auch durchgesetzten
durchgedrückt werden sollte von der CSU
einen sehr Jesus ein umbrühmliches Ende
und die CSU hat einen ganz großen
Schaden für das Land hinterlassen
eigentlich forderten die Betreiber mehr
als eine halbe Milliarde Schadensersatz
das ist nun deutlich weniger ist ein
schwacher Trost
gut sieben Wochen nach der Landtagswahl
in Bremen steht der neue Senat er ist
eine Neuauflage des bisherigen
rot-grün-roten Bündnisses an der Spitze
steht erneut Bürgermeister Andreas
bovenschulte die Bremische Bürgerschaft
wählte den Sozialdemokraten im ersten
Wahlgang er und seine Landesregierung
wollen den Schwerpunkt auf die Bereiche
Bildung Soziales und Klima legen
in die Ukraine das Atomkraftwerk
saporicia wird mehr und mehr zum
unberechenbaren Spielball im Krieg
Moskau und Kiew treffen sich gegenseitig
vor ein Anschlag auf Europas größtes AKW
zu planen russische Truppen haben die
Anlage bereits im März vergangenen
Jahres kurz nach Kriegsbeginn besetzt
für die Menschen in der Region ist das
eine äußerst beunruhigende Situation aus
der Ukraine berichtet daran
seit Kriegsbeginn leben die Menschen in
saporricher mit der Gefahr die vom nahe
gelegenen AKW ausgeht in den letzten
Tagen spitzte sich die Bedrohungslage
weiter zu besonders groß sind die
Befürchtungen und der Flüchtlingen aus
mariopol die aus ihrer zerstörten
Heimatstadt hierher geflohen sind sie
haben auf ein Leben in Sicherheit
gehofft
diese terroristische Bedrohung ist
einfach schrecklich wir versuchen nicht
darüber nachzudenken wir suchen nach
allem was positiv ist in dieser
Situation wir hoffen einfach es wird
nicht geschehen
ukrainische Medien veröffentlichen
Evakuierungspläne im Fall eines GAUs
soll ein Bereich bis zu 50 km um das AKW
evakuiert werden es gibt gegenseitige
Vorwürfe Russland dass das AKW besetzt
hat beschuldigt die Ukraine einen
Angriff auf das AKW zu planen dagegen
sagt Präsident selenski russland habe
auf Dächern des AKWs Gegenstände
angebracht die Spreng setzen ähneln
möglicherweise um einen Terroranschlag
vorzutäuschen
vielleicht gibt es ein anderes Szenario
aber die Welt sieht in jedem Fall dass
die einzige Bedrohung für das
Atomkraftwerk Russland ist und sonst
niemand
beruhigend für die Menschen ist dass die
internationale Atome Energiebehörde
weiterhin Beobachter im AKW beläst und
auch eine Vermietung der Anlage nicht
bestätigen kann
aus Brüssel kommt heute eine Nachricht
die eine Art Zeitenwende in der
Landwirtschaft bedeuten könnte die
EU-Kommission will die Regeln für den
Einsatz von Gentechnik lockern laut
Gesetzentwurf sollen bestimmte
gentechnisch veränderte Pflanzen nicht
mehr gekennzeichnet werden wenn die
Veränderung auch natürlich entstehen
könnte konkret geht es um Erbgut das mit
einer sogenannten genschere bearbeitet
wurde eine präzisen Eingriff an der DNA
über Chancen und Risiken berichtet und
Freller
Hitze ausgetrocknete Böden vernichtete
Ernten der Klimawandel eine
Herausforderung für die Landwirtschaft
deshalb forschen Sie am Leibniz-Institut
in gattersleben an widerstandsfähigeren
Pflanzen Ziel mit Hilfe von neuen
gentechnischen Methoden Getreidesorten
zu entwickeln die weniger Wasser und
weniger Dünger brauchen es ist wichtig
dass wir jetzt die Pflanzen eigenen
Mechanismen mobilisieren und das können
wir eben in dem wir das genomen
editieren das heißt also zum Beispiel
Wurzelwachstum verbessern die Züchtung
dieser super Pflanzen gegen den
Klimawandel ist ein Milliardengeschäft
ein umkämpfter Markt in den USA gibt es
keine Einschränkungen für diese
Gentechnik auch das ist wohl ein Grund
für die EU-Kommission diese Technik zu
unterstützen sie will deshalb das
Gentechnikgesetz lockern damit diese
Pflanzen schneller angebaut werden
können
eine solche genomisch veränderte Pflanze
ist widerstandsfähiger gegen Dürren und
benötigt weniger Pestizide um zu wachsen
kritiker bezweifeln dass diese super
Pflanzen weniger Pestizide brauchen
außerdem dass die EU-Kommission nun die
Kennzeichnung solcher genomisch
veränderter Pflanzen nicht vorschreibt
sei ein Fehler die Bürger müssen wissen
was im Essen ist und das ist ja ein
Recht der Europäischen Union das hier
keine ungeprüften Produkte auf den Markt
dürfen und genau das macht die
Kommission eigentlich ein fundamentaler
Verstoß gegen europäisches Recht Streit
um genomisch veränderte Pflanzen die
EU-Regierungschefs und das EU-Parlament
müssen sich jetzt damit beschäftigen
Gentechnik Regeln lockern wohin der Plan
der EU-Kommission genau führen könnte
das haben wir online noch einmal genau
beleuchtet in unserer ZDF heute App
finden Sie alle Argumente die für und
gegen die Lockerung sprechen
israel hat sein größten Militäreinsatz
im besetzten West jordanland seit
Jahrzehnten offiziell beendet die Armee
hat sich aus der Stadt Jenny
zurückgezogen ziel sei die Zerschlagung
terroristischer Infrastruktur gewesen
die seien nach eigenen Angaben erreicht
worden nach dem Abzug versammelten sich
Tausende Menschen zur Beisetzung
mehrerer getöteter Palästinenser aus
denen berichtet Michael Beverungen
vor allem zerstörte Straßen finden die
Bewohner des Flüchtlingscamps in Genin
heute morgen bei ihrer Rückkehr vor
israelische Bulldozer haben Sie auf der
Suche nach Sprengfallen aufgerissen und
beiseite geschoben was im Weg war aber
auch viele Wasser und Stromleitungen
wurden zerstört die Reparaturarbeiten
werden dauern die Bewohner sind das
schon gewohnt
wir kehren zurück zu unserem normalen
Leben meine Kinder werden mit dem
schutzspielen den die Israelis
hinterlassen haben das was sie immer mit
den Steinen spielen Juden gegen Araber
camela gerieb hat die ganze Zeit während
der Kämpfe im Haus ausgehaucht
wir haben keine Angst vor ihren Waffen
Panzern und Flugzeugen denn gott ist mit
uns
die meisten militanten Kämpfer hatten
sich und ihre Waffen in Sicherheit
gebracht jetzt sind sie zurück
[Applaus]
trotz der vielen Zerstörungen und der
vielen getöteten Kämpfer fühlen sich die
Einwohner von Janine als Sieger noch ist
die Stadt mit dem Wiederaufbau
beschäftigt aber auch die militanten
Kämpfer sind zurückgekehrt und wären
ihre Infrastruktur bald wieder aufgebaut
haben
am Vormittag waren die Toten beerdigt
worden zugleich eine Machtdemonstration
der selbstbewussten genie-brigade die
wirft der Palästinenserführung vor sie
im Stich gelassen zu haben raus raus
schaltest den funktionieren aus Ramada
entgegen es kommt zu einem gefährlichen
Gerammel
der Genie nicht mit uns verteidigt hat
soll auch nicht mit uns trauern
Menschen trauern um ihre Toten und die
radikalen Kräfte haben weiter an Boden
in Genien gewonnen auch das ein Ergebnis
des israelischen Einmarsches
Sommerstürme sind relativ selten aber
gefährlich das zeigt sich gerade an der
Nordseeküste in den Niederlanden und
Niedersachsen wurden zwei Frauen von
umstürzenden Bäumen erschlagen
erst traf ist die Gegend um Amsterdam
dort wüten Böden mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten bis zu 145 km pro
Stunde am frühen Nachmittag zog der
Sturmtief dann an der deutschen
Nordseeküste entlang und liegt aktuell
über Schleswig-Holstein
es sind vor allem die Bäume die polisur
Gewalt zu spüren bekommen das dichte
Sommerurlaub macht sie für die extrem
starken Windböen besonders angreifbar im
Norden der Niederlande wird eine ganze
Baumallee entwurzelt in der Stadt Harlem
bei Amsterdam
hat sich hier konzentriert nur wenige
Meter von hier ist eine Frau gestorben
ein umstürzender Baum hatte die
51-Jährige Autofahrerin unter sich
begraben ihre Verletzungen waren so
schwer dass sie trotz
Reanimationsmaßnahmen starb Poly bewegte
sich weiter in den Nordwesten
Deutschlands im Rede im Emsland wurde
eine Fußgängerin die mit dem Hund
unterwegs war von einem umstürzenden
Baum erschlagen
riesiges Glück hatte die Fahrerin dieses
Wagens in Oldenburg sie überlebte
Gottes ein Baum auf ein feines Fahrzeug
gefallen die Fahrerin war eingeschlossen
in den Fahrzeug wir haben den Fahrzeug
befreit und die Fahrerin ohne Verletzung
aus dem Fahrzeug rausgeholt die war nur
ein geschlossen war aber nicht
eingeklemmt boli ist für viele
Meteorologen schon jetzt ein Fall für
die Geschichtsbücher solche Stürme sind
üblich im Herbst und Winter mitten im
Sommer aber eigentlich nicht Stürme
werden begünstigt durch warme
Temperaturen in den Ozean und derzeit
sind die Ozeane viel zu warm so früh im
Jahr vor allem der Zeit jetzt Anfang
Juli und Ende Juni war es ja auch schon
so und es stehen ja noch einige Monate
uns in diesem Sommer bevor ja und das
ist dann der Treibstoff für Stürmer und
das hat diesmal sicherlich auch mit
gewirkt viele Bahnfahrer in
Norddeutschland mussten heute Geduld
mitbringen weil Bäume auf die Gleise
stürzten und auch den Flugverkehr
machten die starken Windböen zu schaffen
mit schlechten Wetter hat auch das
Tennisturnier in Wimmel zu kämpfen die
vielen Regenunterbrechungen die haben
den Spielplan ganz schön
durcheinandergewirbelt Jannik hanfmann
etwa konnte vorgestern sein Match gegen
Taylor Fritz beim Stand von 2 zu 2 nicht
mehr beenden Fortsetzung erst heute
Nachmittag und da konnte sich dann doch
der US-Amerikaner durchsetzen
nur 17 Minuten dauert die Fortsetzung
hanfmann kann gleich den ersten
Matchball des an Nummer 9 gesetzten
Fritz nicht abwehren muss ich mit vier
zu sechs sechs zu zwei sechs zu vier
fünf zu sieben und drei zu sechs
geschlagen gehen
ausgeschieden ist auch Tatjana Maria die
halbfinalistin von 2022 unterliegt der
Rumänien sorana Christian in drei Sätzen
1 zu 6 6 2 und 3 zu 6 nach
durchwachsener Leistung kann Maria ihr
wimmelten Märchen aus dem Vorjahr nicht
wiederholen
die DFB Frauen haben heute im WM
Trainingslager ein Herzogenaurach vom
sportlichen Leiter der
Nationalmannschaften einen Auftrag
bekommen den Titel holen um damit auch
die deutschen Fans wach zu küssen für
die Fußball-EM der Männer nächsten
Sommer
sie haben ein Team geformt die
Spielerinnen WM tauglich gemacht fähig
Weltmeisterinnen zu werden der deutsche
Kader ist hochwertig besetzt 5
Spielerinnen sind Deutsche Meisterin 10
spielten im Champions League Finale sie
wollen wieder eine Fußball ephorie
entfachen natürlich haben wir unseren
Anspruch wenn wir in einen Turnier gehen
das ist gar keine Frage dass wir um den
Titel mitspielen wollen natürlich würde
ich mich auch freuen wenn unsere Frauen
die deutschen Fußballfans in dem Sommer
noch mal wach küssen können wie bei der
EM im letzten Jahr in sechs Tagen geht's
nach Down Under doch ohne Paulina
Krumbiegel ihr gelangt das 2:1 gegen
Vietnam sie fällt mit muskulären
Problemen aus
zur 5 etappe der Tour de France heute
ging es in die Pyrenäen der erste große
Härtetest für die Radprofis und den
gewann der Australier Jai Hindley vom
einzigen deutschen Team im Rennen Bora
Hansgrohe
der 27 Jahre alte Hindley vor einem Jahr
Sieger des Giro d'Italia fährt ein
klugesrennen lange in einer
Verfolgergruppe die 40 Minuten vor dem
Ziel die Spitzengruppe einholt dann
setzt er sich selbst 20 Kilometer vor
Lara ab Sieg souverän mit 32 Sekunden
Vorsprung und ist bei seinem Tour Debüt
ganz aus dem Häuschen
unglaublich mir fehlen die Worte
zweiter wird der Italiener Giulio
chicone vor dem Österreicher Felix Gall
und dem Deutschen Meister Immanuel
Buchmann dem gilt der Dank von Sieger
Henley für seine wichtige
Unterstützungsarbeit in den Bergen der
Pyrenäen der Australier übernimmt auch
das Gelbe Trikot des Gesamtführenden
morgen geht's dann auf den berüchtigten
turmallee
18 Sportarten 159 deutsche Meistertitel
vier Wettkampftage an Rhein-Ruhr das
sind die Final 2023 und heute am späten
Nachmittag die feierliche Eröffnung in
Düsseldorf Athletin und Athleten der
gerade zu Ende gegangenen Special
Olympics World Games übergeben
teilnehmen der finalsymbolisch einen
Staffelstein
und die ersten Entscheidung live bei uns
im ZDF morgen zu sehen ab 14:15 Uhr
und zum Schluss noch was für die Fans
des royalen kleine Quizfrage wie viele
Kronen hat Charles II als König
überreicht bekommen Antwort seit heute
drei zwei englische und jetzt kam noch
diese dazu die schottische feierlich
überreicht samter und Schwert in
Edinburg die Sache hat allerdings einen
Haken anfassen dafür die Krone mitnehmen
in den heimischen Palast kommt aber
nicht in Frage in die Krone darf
Schottland nie verlassen so stets im
schottischen Grundgesetz
und diese Lottozahlen wurden heute
gezogen sie lauten 2 16 20 23 34 44
Superzahl ist die 3 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 557
mehr zum sommerurkan Poly erfahren Sie
gleich im Wetter von östindelli
Christian Sievers begrüßt sie um 21.45
zum heute-journal schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter wir sehen hier
Polly das außergewöhnliche Orkantief mit
einem Sommer und das hat sich Richtung
Nordsee verlagert und wir sehen hier es
gefährdet hier noch die nordfriesischen
Inseln hier können durchaus noch
Gewitter entstehen und dann sind auch
noch mal orkanartige Bühne oder
vielleicht sogar Orkanböen möglich in
der Nacht zieht das ganze allmählich
nordwärts raus der Wind lässt auch
allmählich nach letzte Sturm teils
schwere Sturmböen eventuell orkanartige
Bösen sind noch dabei die verziehen sich
ansonsten gibt's Schauer im Westen und
im Süden bei tiefsten Temperaturen von 7
Grad in der Eifel und 13 Grad in Bayern
und morgen dann im Norden einige Schauer
die durchziehen der Wind ist nicht mehr
so heftig kommt aus West an den Alpen
einzelne Gewittern und die Temperaturen
bei 20 bis 28 Grad aber die Steigung des
Sonntag kräftig an wir erwarten eine
Hitzewelle Temperaturen bis 37 Grad im
Südwesten und 25 Grad ganz im Norden die
nächsten Tage ja am Freitag relativ
ruhig und danach kommen Gewitter auf und
es wird heiß schöner Abend